nous considérons que dans la situation
actuelle où plus que jamais le pouvoir
fait preuve de son incapacité à résoudre
les problèmes posés devant notre pays
seul le programme commun de la gauche
ouvre une alternative réelle au pays
l'offensive que nous allons nous lançons
à nouveau en faveur du programme commun
revêt un double aspect d'une part nous
proposons au parti socialiste
au parti radical à l'expliquer nous
sommes d'ailleurs en discussion mais
aussi à toutes les organisations
syndicales et professionnelles
d'organiser une coopération commune
active en faveur du programme commun et
nous sommes prêts à discuter
immédiatement quelle est la réaction du
parti communiste aux récentes
déclarations de monsieur lecanu et
jean-jacques servan-schreiber tout
simplement que cela ne fait que
confirmer ce que nous avions dit déjà
depuis longtemps
lecanu naturellement non seulement est
prêt à entrer la majorité mais il
propose concrètement maintenant la
coopération avec cette majorité et il
devient évident pour beaucoup de gens
que lorsque jean-jacques
servan-schreiber a fait main basse sur
le parti radical
c'était tout simplement pour les mecs
dans les bras de monsieur pompidou et
cela pour le compte du grand capital